[Music]
you've waited a week but now it's time
for final exam a battle of returning
champions this week special port host
bret baier one you'll remember last week
chief national correspondent Henry one
two weeks ago but was out last week two
champions enter only one will emerge the
video the rules I'm gonna repeat them
anyway for audience hands on buzzers I'm
gonna ask the questions the first one to
buzz in gets to answer the question you
must wait until I finish asking a
question in order to buzz each correct
answer is worth one point if you get it
wrong as in the SAT you lose a point
best of five wins it's ready
nerve-racking big advice live television
one the oldest sitting senator in
America is having problems with the
re-election campaign the Democratic
Party in her state refuses to support
her who is it
Bret Baier Dianne Feinstein Ella
Feinstein of California says the anchor
of special report to the tape this is
not an easy time the door on Senator
Dianne Feinstein party activists denying
the state's senior senator an
endorsement in her bid for re-election
so the next question is fair balanced
and question two multiple choice did you
know that you can clone your pets indeed
you can Barbra Streisand reveals this
week that she did she cloned her
favorite dog who was named Samantha what
is the going rate for dog cloning is it
fifty thousand dollars five hundred
thousand or 1 million dollars it Henry
50 thousand 50 thousand said Edie the
would-be dog cloner to the tape she
cloned her dogs two of her dogs miss
violet and miss Scarlett are clones of
the late dog samantha who passed on last
year at about fifty thousand dollars a
problem
I did here kill me but I heard Laura
Ingram talk about if you've got a pet
cloning question question three Oprah
says a 2020 presidential run could be
possible but she's waiting for a certain
someone to give her the explicit go
ahead who is she waiting to hear from oh
wait
God but wait what's that prima donna
hold on only our vote only are our
judges because I by passing those
responsibilities can determine this I
did both of them click in early well
only add clicked in early early this is
like the Anna okay I'm sorry sorry this
is deflategate at this point and I am
NOT going to be the NFL Commissioner so
I'm just gonna go right to the judges
who say we're going to have a reclick
okay of the same question same question
here we go we haven't finished it who
are you ready yes she's she's waiting
for a certain someone to give her the
go-ahead who is she waiting to hear from
the Almighty God the Almighty God says
that Henry to the tape billionaires is
calling me up saying I can get you a
billion dollars I can run your campaign
and I actually went into prayer about it
like God if you if you think I'm
supposed to run you gotta tell me and it
has to be so clear that not even I could
miss it don't tell joy behar only God
can be your campaign manager like
there's nobody adequate to that question
that was controversial trust me it was
and some of the great moments are okay
question for the Department of Housing
and Urban Development Secretary Ben
Carson is accused of spending over 30
grand on a necessary furniture what kind
of furniture was it
but bears early dining sex dining set I
don't have a dining set okay we'll find
out in the tape is it a dining set
Carson reportedly spent thirty one
thousand taxpayer dollars on a new
dining set for his private dining room
in DC now our hot official is quoted as
saying that a career staffer was behind
the decision to buy the dining set not
secretary Kirsten Wow okay so I was a
humanities major so I'm going to check
the judges for the math where are we now
- the - so this is it this is a
tiebreaker final question it's multiple
choice there is a man currently running
for Congress in the state of Arkansas he
shares a name with a rock and roll
legend is he named a Elvis Presley B
Bruce Springsteen or C makjang or ed
Henry Louis Presley Elvis Presley is is
that his name and you now win the
coveted Eric wimple mug that shows
Washington Post Carr thought it was the
tucker carlson
on the back bear thank you yeah that was
controversial but I felt when shannon
bream thank you gentle thanks guys tune
in to the news each week and then tune
in to final exam see if you can
outperform our news professionals